[Musique]
parler parler vite vous d'abord je m'appelle
Sarah Connor Le 29 août 1997 était
censé être le jour du jugement dernier mon fils John et j'ai
arrêté de sauver trois milliards de vies assez
d'un CV car vous savez
peut-être avoir changé l'avenir mais vous
n'avez pas changé  notre destin
qu'est-ce que tu n'as jamais vu comme toi
avant presque humain
je suis ici ils sont juste améliorés mettons
quelque chose au clair c'est ma mission
de la protéger si tu la mets en danger
je vais te [ __ ] en l'air je conduis
attends un grand frère de douleur  tout le corps est
une arme garde le pour les dames désolé
je reviens
écoute tout le monde meurt si tu n'y arrives
pas comment on arrête ce truc tu ne le
combats pas
tu le fuis
tu crois au destin Ciara
c'est tout
tu sais quand nous aurons fini je vais
te tuer
toi toi